that I would recommend.
>> NEW YORK HAD THE HIGHEST
DEATH RATE IN THE WORLD HOW CAN
WE POSSIBLY BE JUMPING UP AND
DOWN SAYING OH, GOVERNOR CUOMO
DID A GREAT JOB.
HE HAD THE WORST DEATH RATE IN
THE WORLD.
>> NO, YOU MISCONSTRUED THAT,
SENATOR, AND YOU’VE DONE THAT
REPETITIVELY IN THE PAST.
>> WE’RE NOT SPREADING THE
INFECTION ISN’T IT JUST
THEATRE?
IT’S THE KNOW THE VACCINE AND
YOU’RE WEARING TWO MASKS ISN’T
THAT THEATRE?
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN WITH THE
THEATRE.
>> DR. FAUCI DO YOU STILL
SUPPORT FUNDING OF THE  NIH
FUNDING OF THE LAB IN
WUHAN?
>> SENATOR PAUL, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, YOU ARE ENTIRELY AND
COMPLETELY INCORRECT.
I DON’T FAVOR GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH IN CHINA.
YOU WERE SAYING THINGS THAT ARE
NOT CORRECT.
STEVE: OH, MAN THE SPARKS FLY
WHEN DR. FAUCI IS INTERROGATED,
LET’S SAY, BY KENTUCKY SENATOR
RAND PAUL, A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION HEALTH AND
LABOR PENSIONS COMMITTEE, AND
THE SENATOR JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: WELL YOU’RE A DOCTOR SO
YOU’VE GOT SPECIAL DOCTOR
QUESTIONS OF THE DOCTOR.
HE DOES NOT PARTICULARLY LIKE IT
HE WAS ASKED THIS MORNING OVER
ON ANOTHER CHANNEL ABOUT THE
GIVE AND TAKE BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU.
HE HAD THIS TO SAY.
>> COULD I JUST ASK ABOUT YOU
AND RAND PAUL?
DOES YOUR BODY TENSE UP EVERY
TIME?
>> [LAUGHTER]
>> AND BY BODY YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, GAIL, I JUST
DON’T WANT TO GET INTO THAT
TIT-FOR-TAT.
I JUST DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS WITH HIM, BUT YOU
KNOW?
I’M JUST GOING TO DO MY JOB AND
HE CAN DO WHAT HE WANTS TO DO
AND WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
STEVE: SENATOR HE SAYS HE’S JUST
GOING TO DO HIS JOB BUT THAT
SEEMS TO BE WHAT YOU’VE GOT A
PROBLEM WITH HOW HE’S DOING HIS
JOB.
>> IF HE WAS BEING INTERVIEWED
BY A JOURNALIST THEY WOULD HAVE
ASKED, DID THE  NIH, DID YOUR
SPECIFIC DIVISION OF THE  NIH
GIVE MONEY TO THE WUHAN
LAB.
THAT’S TRUE.
WHAT HE’S ARGUING IS HE’S
PARSING HIS WORDS.
HE KNOWS HIS GROUP GAVE MONEY,
BUT HE’S SAYING OH, IT WASN’T
FOR JUICING UP THESE SUPER VIRUS
ES.
WE GAVE IT FOR OTHER RESEARCH.
IT’S SORT OF LIKE THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ARGUMENT.
YES WE GIVE TAXPAYER MONEY TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, BUT NOT FOR
ABORTION.
DR. FAUCI IS ARGUING YEAH, WE
GAVE IT, THE  NIH AND MY GROUP
SPECIFICALLY GAVE IT TO THE
WUHAN LAB BUT THEY WEREN’T
SUPPOSED TO BE JUICING UP VIRUS
ES.
STEVE: THE MONEY IS FUNGIBLE AS
YOU SAY ON CAPITOL
HILL.
>> IT’S EVEN WORSE THAN THAT,
THE BAT SCIENTIST THAT’S THE
MOST FAMOUS ONE FOR THE
WUHAN INSTITUTE WHEN SHE
PUBLISHED HER PAPERS, WHICH
SCIENTISTS ACROSS-THE-BOARD ARE
SAYING ARE GAIN OF FUNCTION,
THEY WERE JUICING UP VIRUSES,
THEY GAVE CREDIT TO DR. FAUCI.
SHE SAID THE FUNDING CAME FROM,
WE HAVE THIS IN BLACK AND WHITE,
FROM A PEER REVIEW JOURNAL.
SHE SAID THE FUNDING CAME FROM
DR. FAUCI’S NATIONAL INSTITUTE A
ID, THIS IS DR. FAUCI
’S BABY FOR 40 YEARS
AND SHE LISTS HIM IN THE CREDITS
HE CAN’T ESCAPE THIS.
HE DID THE FUNDING AND MY OTHER
QUESTION IS CHINA IS A RICH
COUNTRY AND THEY’RE KICKING OUR
BUTT IN SO MANY PLACES.
WHY WOULD WE BE GIVING THEM
MONEY FOR RESEARCH?
WILL: SENATOR PAUL, DR. FAUCI
CALLS YOUR EXCHANGE A
TIT-FOR-TAT AND HE SAID HE
DOESN’T MONTH WHAT YOUR PROBLEM
IS.
THAT’S BECAUSE HE’S PLACED ON A
PEDESTAL AND NO ONE THINKS IT’S
APPROPRIATE TO QUESTION HIM NO
ONE EXCEPT FOR YOU AND A FEW
OTHERS.
HAVE YOU RECEIVED THE ANSWERS
YOU WANT?
WE SAW IN THAT CLIP YOU’RE
ASKING ABOUT USING NEW YORK AS A
MODEL, WHY YOU SHOULD BE MASKED
WHEN YOU’VE ALREADY RECEIVED THE
VACCINE AND IMPORTANTLY WHAT
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
MORNING.
THE ORIGINS OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
HE SAID TO YOU DIRECTLY, THAT’S
NOT TRUE, REGARDING HIS SUPPORT
OF GAIN OF FUNCTION.
WHEN WE KNOW THERE’S AN
EDITORIAL GOING BACK TO 2011
THAT HE HAS SUPPORTED GAIN
OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
HAVE YOU RECEIVED THE ANSWERS
YOU’RE LOOKING FOR , SENATOR?
>> NO BUT WE’VE SENT INQUIRIES.
THERE’S BEEN FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION AS WELL AS INQUIRIES
FROM HOUSE OVERSIGHT, WHEN IT
WAS UNDER REPUBLICANS AND NOW
FROM OUR OFFICE, RON JOHNSON AND
OTHERS.
WE’RE ASKING SPECIFICALLY FOR
SOME NIH PAPERS AND THE
CONCLUSIONS BECAUSE IN THOSE
CONCLUSIONS, WE BELIEVE IT
WILL BE UNEQUIVOCAL FROM A GROUP
OF SCIENTISTS THAT THEY WILL
CONCLUDE THE YES THAT WUHAN
INSTITUTE WAS MAKING THESE SUPER
-VIRUSES.
THEY ARE STILL GOING TO ARGUE
THEY DIDN’T FUND IT BUT THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT ARGUMENT.
IT’S NOT A PARTISAN ARGUMENT SO
WHEN DR. FAUCI GOES ON THESE
OTHER CHANNELS AND THEY LAUGH IT
UP BUT THEY NEVER ASK HIM, DID
YOU FUND THE INSTITUTE.
SO HE’S TRYING TO EVADE THAT HE
FUNDED IT AT ALL.
I ASK HIM THE GENERAL QUESTION,
I DIDN’T ASK HIM WHETHER HE
FUNDED GAIN OF FUNCTION.
I SAID DID THE  NIH FUND THE
WUHAN LAB AND HE DANCED
AROUND IT AND ANSWERED A
DIFFERENT QUESTION, BUT THERE IS
NO QUESTION AT ALL THAT THE  NIH
FUNDED THIS LAB WHETHER
IT WAS GAIN OF FUNCTION, THERE’S
MANY SCIENTISTS, DR.  BALTIMORE,
MANY SCIENTISTS OUT THERE, THERE
WERE 200 SCIENTISTS IN THE
CAMBRIDGE WORKING GROUP THAT
ARE WORRIED ABOUT CREATING THESE
SUPERVIRUSES IN THE LAB AND THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY COULD
GET OUT SO IT ISN’T JUST ME,
IT’S NOT PARTISAN POLITICS.
SHOULDN’T BE PARTISAN AT ALL.
WE SHOULD WANT TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN CASE ANOTHER VIRUS
LIKE THIS COULD ESCAPE.
AINSLEY: THIS IS SO CRAZY THOUGH
, BECAUSE IF THIS HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF THE  NIH FUNDING AND
THAT CAME FROM DR. FAUCI AND
THIS SPREADS INTO A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND NOW HE’S IN CHARGE
OF THE RESPONSE IN THE UNITED
STATES, THE IRONY OF THAT, WHAT
DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> IT’S EVEN WORSE THAN YOU
MAKE OUT.
THE PERSON THEY APPOINTED TO
INVESTIGATE THE LAB FROM THE  W.
H. O. PERSPECTIVE IS THE GUY WHO
GAVE THE MONEY, SO NIH GAVE THE
MONEY TO A GROUP CALLED ECO
HEALTH.
THE HEAD OF  ECO HEALTH, THEY
GOT HIM TO INVESTIGATE WHETHER
WUHAN WAS DOING ANYTHING
INAPPROPRIATE IN THEIR LAB, BUT
IF THEY WERE, WOULDN’T HE THEN
BE CULPABLE?
SO DOESN’T HE HAVE A SELF-
INTEREST IN SMOOTHING
THINGS OVER?
I’M NOT SAYING HE DID COVER
THINGS UP BUT YOU WOULDN’T
APPOINT SOMEONE WHOSE IN THE
LINE OF SUPPLY CHAIN OF
GIVING THE MONEY TO THEM BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY HERE IS THE RUB.
I DON’T KNOW WHETHER IT CAME
FROM THE LAB.
NOBODY KNOWS WHETHER IT CAME
FROM THE LAB, BUT WHO BE
CULPABLE?
DR. FAUCI TO BE CULPABLE FOR THE
ENTIRE PANDEMIC?
SO COULD DR.  DAZANK, AND SO
COULD DR.  XI.
I’M NOT SAYING THAT HAPPENED I
DON’T KNOW, BUT YOU WOULDN’T PUT
THE PEOPLE WHO GAVE THE MONEY TO
THE WUHAN LAB IN CHARGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A COVER-UP.
STEVE: NO KIDDING AND IT’S
CURIOUS THAT IT SEEMS LIKE THE
ONLY PEOPLE ASKING ABOUT THE
ORIGIN OF THE CORONAVIRUS
WHICH HAS KILLED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS ALL SEEM
TO BE REPUBLICANS, WHICH IS ODD.
>> THERE SHOULD BE BIPARTISAN
CONCERN.
THERE’S 11 LABS IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT ARE COOKING UP AND
CREATING SUPER-VIRUSES.
THAT’S WORRISOME.
STEVE: JUSTER THE TURN SUPER